and more breaking news right now our
i-team learning new details this noon
hour in the death of two-year-old amari
nicholson
the i-team's david charns joining us now
in studio with what we know hi david
hey there alex so according to terrell
rhodes arrest report which the i-team
was first to get the man caring for
amari nicholson told police he
hit the two-year-old with his fist
several times
killing him police also just releasing
this photo of terrell rhodes this is his
booking photo
the i-team first telling you when police
arrested rhodes for amari's murder back
on tuesday afternoon
investigators say during an interview
that same day rhodes told them he got
upset
after the toddler soiled himself hitting
his body three or four times with
a closed fist now this report also says
rhodes did attempt cpr but it was just
too late
he then carried amari's body out of the
emerald suites
this all happened early in the morning
last wednesday may 5th
the day amari was reported missing
investigators finding the boy's body
just nearby there yesterday the report
also saying terrell called amari's
mother taylor
saying the boy had been abducted and
then taylor called 911
now as early as a week ago today police
writing these documents they found
traces of blood
on a wall in the apartment they all
shared and a bag of soiled clothing in a
closet
much more and all this starting this
afternoon at four o'clock and all day
inside our free app i'm david charns 8
news now alex